Morphing is the process of changing from one model to another. It's a fairly
tricky problem to solve if the two objects are quite different. For example, if
I want to morph a cube into a unicorn model, I'll have to create a bunch of
vertices on the cube and decide how these move in a convincing way. Much
simpler is to
[UNKNOWN]
between two meshes with the same number of vertices. In this case, linear
interpolation between the two meshes is trivial. A more general approach uses
what are called morph targets or key poses. A simple example is a smile. Say we
have three poses, a neutral pose, a smile an a frown. To go from one to the
other we can interpolate. Essentially the key poses are similar to key frames
to interpolate between. By changing the amount of influence a particular target
has affects the result. For example, I could specify a half smile by saying to
have each vertex be half the neutral pose, half the smile pose. A further
advantage of morph targets is that they can be combined. For example, I could
have key poses for an eyebrow and use it as I wish with a smile or frown. A
pose can be associated with parts of a mesh and so influence only them. For
example, here I'm using the wonderful ginger demo by Stickman Ventures. They'e
a slighter set on many different facial features. By changing a setting, I'm
changing the influence of the morph target. Even skinned models can be exported
and treated as morph targets. Morph targets are well supported by 3JS and so
are a popular way to display animated models. The main drawback on the modeling
end is that it's labor intensive to create morph targets. The whole process of
setting up a character's animation controls is called rigging, and one that
take skill and time to do properly. Such processes are almost always done with
interactive modelling and animation programs. Another drawback is that morphing
needs much more data than skinning while running an animation, both to download
and to keep in the GPU's memory. All that said, morphing has the advantage of
being generic. Any model changes can be saved into morph targets and there's no
real ambigity. Skinning cannon is done in a myriad of different ways with
research continuing to find new techniques. Lots of tears have been shed by
many developers trying to convert skinning animations from one format to
another.